[Music]
the book does have some pragmatic and
concrete suggestions
the first is stop hating ourselves for
for participating in digital culture
it's a real drag on our health and our
immune system to spend our time on our
phones or on on our laptops or in other
kinds of digital space using GPS
technology thinking that there's
something wrong with us for doing it so
that's that's the first thing that the
that the book you know ask really asks
people to do just for an hour to imagine
the internet is not a neurotoxin it's
not causing brain damage it's an
opportunity and an opportunity to use
wholeheartedly to use with confidence to
use with dignity to use with all your
humanity
now each of the forms has its own
constraints so if you're using text
online to show up to consumers or to
meet your friends then there are certain
there certain considerations and there
are the considerations that poets have
made sense of so one of them one of the
most beautiful things I've ever heard
said about how poets construct their
their sentences their phrases their
their their lines is that and this is
Helen van Laar the great the great
critic of poetry she says that at every
moment after every word any word can
follow it next so in the gap between two
words the you give the impression or the
illusion that you have that any word is
possible and the reader should feel just
a slight slight micron intake of breath
like what could come next so for
companies showing up online surprise
delight how do you use that little space
between words so that you don't you know
say you are leveraging a cliche like at
the end of the day right you that you
don't maybe it's at the end of the
millennium maybe it's a different word
there other than day you know when you
think of of beautiful slogans that
capture something in our minds they're
surprising you know they're delightful
there there you know I didn't expect it
to go in that direction
the same is true for Twitter you know
when you look at political candidates
that have used Twitter well like I must
say Donald Trump you don't know what
he's going to say next
you know he's he's he has us you know he
has us in suspense all the time and that
suspense is very important I think
brands have had a hard time building
suspense because it's nerve-racking a
little bit to take those kind of risks
but it's necessary as for images learn
the vernacular of a place like like like
Instagram it's not easy
I just tried the other night to learn
the Instagram via the idiom of twitch to
learn to read up thread as they say on
Twitch and most of the vocabulary was
entirely new to me you know I didn't
realize that grill is a girl that when
Melania Trump was described as salt that
that was an allusion to an Angelina
Jolie movie from 2010 but this kind of
shorthand you don't look at that kind of
shorthand say on Instagram the grammar
of Instagram whether you use filters or
not the move to no filter away from you
know the very highly aestheticized use
of the of the latter filters you know
that's something that brands should know
and are required to know the third form
I talk about is design so one of the one
of the interesting hallmarks of design
online is that the expedient design on
the World Wide Web that junkie non
design that you see on you know some of
the early services like Yahoo and and
and and Yahoo and AOL and that is you
know really determined to read the
reader so while you're involved in it
it's collecting data from you and it's
you know it's trying like a like a like
a souk like an open market to kind of
pick your pocket at every turn and you
have to be on guard against it so that's
an experience that some that some
internet users like or at least tolerate
in order to try to get the resources of
those sites then you look at the use of
apps that have resurrected Japanese
design Italian design Scandinavian
design and some of the tropes of the
20th century that were associated with
higher
so recognizing that split is very very
important and recognizing also that
there's an elitist and a populist split
you spend all your time on apps then you
have no exposure to the vocabulary that
generated the campaign of Donald Trump
or that makes Red Bull you know such a
compelling brand you know you don't
touch the edge of people you live
entirely on these beautiful removed apps
and you're missing something from the
human experience so figuring out a way
was designed to show up online and maybe
show up on mobile is a challenge for
brands and for and for new businesses
the other parts of the book treat music
treat treat video which is obviously an
extremely compelling part of the
Internet
partly because videos graph so well onto
ads but you know YouTube has a grammar
almost like nothing else it can be very
opaque it needs to be studied
you need digital natives or at least
people who are like really emotionally
drawn to YouTube in order and snapchat
in order to use it properly and and with
proper respect for how it works you know
it's extraordinary to me that a campaign
will drop into a form out of nowhere or
you see brands doing this on Twitter all
the time without any understanding of
how hashtags work or tagging works and
then last music now music is you know a
world of its own and it's probably worth
taking a look at the chapter on music at
least to understand all the ups and
downs of it but typically you know
typically digital a visual culture and a
text culture is silent we don't like
unwanted sound on the internet we don't
like unwanted sound from our phones
we're always being asked to silence them
and so music is has to be a powerful
experience and also a live experience
companies that have have embraced the
return of live culture in the form of
conferences concerts are are doing well
they're embracing the future but that
maker culture foodism all those things
that can't be digitized you know that
like a live concert are you know are the
future that push back on the
or not is the future
[Music]